[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the guardian's chief political
correspondent jessica elgot and the
sun's political editor harry cole so a
very good evening to both of you and i'm
very pleased to say that you will be
with us through until just before
midnight so thanks for joining us
let's take a look then first of all at
what's on the front pages and the eye
says that thousands of british families
have already signed up to host refugees
after the announcement of a government
scheme
the sun leads with the same story saying
43 000 brits have offered to take in
refugees
the daily mail also leads with that
story saying caring britain's rush to
join new scheme
three brits killed in missile hell is
the headline for the daily mirror as
they report on the polish border strike
over the weekend
and the guardian also looks at the
developing situation in ukraine their
headline russia's deadly raids plunge
ukrainians into nightmare
china signaled willingness to provide
russia with military support says u.s
that's the front of the financial times
that's their main headline
the daily telegraph reports on comments
made by boris johnson about the west's
dependence on russian oil and gas their
headline west made terrible mistake with
putin says pm
and the metro leads on the protesters
who stormed the home of a russian
oligarch in london their headline your
putin putin us up mate i'm gonna
practice that and do it better next hour
and just a reminder that by scanning the
qr code that you can see on screen
during the program you can check out
those front pages of tomorrow's papers
for yourself while you watch us
so let's bring in then uh journalist
jessica elgat and harry cole good to see
you both jessica a number of the front
pages lead with this new government
scheme
encouraging people to offer rooms in
their houses to ukrainian refugees let's
start with um the sun
they say uk rain ukraine they're on
their front page
yeah and it really is i mean just for a
week of what has been particularly grim
news and of course this comes on the
back of such a terrible crisis but it is
heartwarming ultimately heartwarming to
see how many um tens of thousands of
people and that's only in the first
hours of this scheme are prepared to to
essentially offer up their homes and for
ukrainian refugees to come along with
them people they haven't met people who
don't have a connection to the uk that's
that's actually you know people with a
separate scheme
and you know this is no small endeavor
it's offering a space in your house for
a minimum of six months as michael gove
and set out today and and people have
embraced that and
cabinet ministers have embraced that
grant shap said he would be offering one
and and and so did the former health
secretary matt hancock i know also of
another um labour shadow minister who
says he'll be doing it as well so and
you know i think that there are probably
some when you look at the details
there's some criticisms you could you
could make of it i think there are
you know difficulties logistically but
on the face of it it's a phenomenal
achievement to have so many people come
forward well that's right and it's on
makes the front page of the daily mail
as well harry it's also on the front of
the eye these extraordinary numbers i
think the website did crash because of
so many people coming forward to put
themselves up for this which is
incredibly heartening isn't it i mean do
you feel this is
the answer for housing refugees do you
think it's it's right that the public
take take responsibility here
well i don't think there's the
government really had any choice if you
could be slightly cynical about it and
i'm
just said exactly what i feel it is
heartwarming after two three weeks of
horrific
news and this government insiders late
last week was saying look just wait you
know we're getting in the neck now
because we're not taking you know we
haven't just thrown open our borders
we're balancing the security of the
country versus the
capacity of what we can do but just you
know just wait because i think they knew
this would work michael gove in
particular uh downing street were very
very clear they wanted to get us off the
they wanted this scheme to land to land
correctly for it to be up and running
properly before they opened it up
because they knew actually the goodness
of the british people would probably
throw open their their doors now scratch
beneath the surface a bit and you've got
a realization that actually because of
the large amount of asylum claims we
have from the channel um because of uh
influxes of
genuine refugees and asylum seekers from
conflicts with syria and libya in
afghanistan the british housing stock
local town housing local town halls
housing stock is pretty much saturated
we're spending 1.5 million pounds
every single day roughly give or take uh
on hotels
for for for for asylum seekers who want
to come to this country while their
claims are being processed because
there's not enough flats or houses to to
put them up in now what do you do in a
situation like that when there's a
possibility of another possibly hundreds
of thousands of people from ukraine
desperately needing shelter you have to
open up that massive spare housing
capacity that britain has and if they
pull this off i genuinely think this
will go down in in modern political
history as a as an incredible move
because you've taken an actual real
headache problem that this how this
country has is that town councils just
don't have enough
enough rooms to shelter people and blown
open another problem in britain which is
lots of people are sitting on lots of
spare capacity in their private homes
and if you can make that work that's a
great public policy
a very quick word on how this was
announced at jessica it's announced by
michael gove was that a surprise did you
think this should be pretty patel who
was announcing this scheme
i think we knew from late last week that
that michael gove was going to sort of
take the reigns on this and and if
you're going to be quite generous uh
as to why you might say well you know
this is a lot of this involves close
liaison with local governments a lot of
the people coming over are people who
will um are women and children uh
they're probably likely to need more
support than people who could just
come over here and start working
immediately without you know having
dependents to worry about lots of them
will have um partners husbands
boyfriends you know fighting in ukraine
a lot of them will have small children
or they might be elderly and therefore
they're likely to need quite a lot of
local council support i think that's one
of the things that councils are kind of
slightly on edge about
about how much support they that they
will get and the government has
announced some um and so yeah you can
understand kind of why it's michael gove
announcing this but you know
cruelly speaking some people government
will say he was the person to grip this
rather than british patel um let's move
on to um one of the other topics
inevitably being covered by the papers
harry and that's what's going on on the
ground in ukraine as the bombardments
continue the guardian has made that
their main headline russia's deadly
raids plunge ukrainians into nightmare
and there are some horrific statistics
in this article aren't there
yeah the
the the first two
three weeks two and a half weeks of this
conflict the ukrainian
armed forces have put up a phenomenal
resistance um they they are you know
armed with with western weapons they
have really have stopped putin's war
machine
in its tracks however
it is at the end of the day going to be
a numbers game and the overwhelming
force that putin has is
speaking to the defense sources and and
sort of wiser hands sort of late last
week when everyone was thinking oh my
god you know they could actually turn
the tide here was pleading caution
because
yes while the russians have sustained
huge losses that war machine just will
keep on coming and if you have a
construct army and you're not you know
worried about the scale of losses you
are just going to keep pushing and keep
pushing and i fear we're starting now in
in the last three or four days actually
to see the grim reality of that that yes
resistance can only go so far but if
you're up against mike force you are
gonna eventually see these devastating
scenes and it's becoming increasingly
clear that in his frustrations that his
efforts to conquer ukraine have not gone
as efficiently as planned um we're
seeing a much more blunter instrument of
force uh in the widespread shelling and
flattening of of hospitals maternity
hospitals a mosque over the weekend um
pretty indiscriminate um action and um
the people that sort of just and i speak
to and are briefing us sir definitely
saying look this is this is going to get
a lot grimmer uh very quickly well yes
and it quotes the red cross saying that
the number of who have fleed the
countries is around 3 million now and
conditions for those left behind were
they say nothing short of a nightmare um
jessica let's move on to the daily
telegraph though because the prime
minister boris johnson has written
for the paper
tomorrow morning
talking about what the headline says it
west made terrible mistake with putin
but also talking about the implications
of cutting some of the ties with russia
not least energy supplies
yes and he likens vladimir putin's use
of russian energy supplies to blackmail
and says simply that the you know the
the west cannot go on with this kind of
reliance and here he
essentially argues that banning imports
of russian
hydrocarbons will start will you know be
the final thing that starves um the
russian president and you know and he
doesn't say this but ultimately the
russian people have money um
but he also talks about a very painful
period of adjustment and one of the
things that he makes quite clear in the
pieces that he still you know he still
is committed to the to to the net zero
target and and it has to and the uk has
to become a net zero emitter by
50s essentially saying that you know the
drive towards renewable energy is isn't
the problem here um but you know as
harry's piece you know
points out that that that doesn't
necessarily
you we're all going to think see this
government make some choices that that
that people the environmentalists aren't
going to be that happy with um when
that's you know delaying the closure of
of coal of coal plants as harris
reporting tonight well yes so harry
let's go to your article inside the sun
tomorrow morning um a lot of concern
obviously about what um about
if we cut off russian supplies what that
does to global prices and already we've
seen prices going up hugely they're
going up before at the invasion of
ukraine so what have you found out about
uh what rishi sunac might do to try and
alleviate some of the pain
well the governor faced with a bit of a
headache uh because next week they've
got a mini budget um which
for months and months is meant to be
sort of richie uh soonax sort of you
know i've fixed i fixed the economy
after covered a bit of a a bit of a
victory lap but this is now fast turning
into a what the hell do we do to to to
tackle this soaring costs at the pumps
now another record day on sunday for
both diesel and petrol now the price of
crude is fluctuating but you know
experts are telling the treasury
committee in the house of commons today
that they're expecting 18 months of
fluctuations and the general trend for
oil prices is going to go up the prime
minister touches on this quite
euphemistically in his piece saying
there's going to be months of pain but
that months of pain actually means
people not being able to afford to go to
work parents not being afford to go to
to drive their children to school
teachers not being able to get to you
know get to get to their jobs it's going
to be very brutal if the cost of petrol
as is projected could possibly do
peak at two pounds a liter the
government are going to have to slash
fuel duty because
at the same time as petrol is going up
their vat take uh is increasing so the
treasury are actually profiting from
fuel prices being very expensive so
my feeling is the the political mood the
wind is blowing towards a cut in fuel
duty which we've been campaigning for as
a paper next week france has done it
i'll have done it czech republic have
done it portuguese have done it i can't
see how politically they get away with
allowing record prices and record
profits of the treasury and expect to
survive as a government meant to be on
the side of the workers